la matière revient partout dans le monde
on a un exemple ici dans cette usine
avec ces granules de plastique qui
proviennent de partout dans le monde on
fabrique plus de 2000 produits
différents ici on préfère utiliser de la
résine de plastique neuf plutôt que de
la matière recyclée au québec
l'accord qui est en importation brosseau
vous devez acheter la matière première
en asie
en cinq ans la super bonne question de
coût pour nous transformer la matière et
ce n'est et plus coûteux que transformer
la matière les centres de tri ont envoyé
l'an passé 59 mille tonnes de plastique
chez les conditionneurs avec la chute
des prix le fait que les matières 9 vers
cycliques val la même chose sur les
marchés la plupart des fabricants de
produits de plastique achètent
maintenant leur matière première à
l'extérieur du québec plutôt que chez
les conditionneurs québécois résultat
les conditionneurs ont de la difficulté
à vendre leur plastique ce qui vient des
centres de tri bush dick cheney de free
ride un brin d'humour et ce n'est pas
continue à baisser
je vais d'objets de faire mais avec le
temps comme plusieurs conditionneurs au
québec qui ont de la difficulté pour ce
conditionneurs aussi les temps sont
difficiles il a réduit sa production de
moitié qui rien ne change
des gens comme vous
des conditionnements n'avons de moyens
d'arriver au québec
2 - arbres qui vont rester deux portes
de sortie l'exportation ont
l'enfouissement ans - on est là on est
là là un moment donné il y aura plus un
entrepreneur qui va vouloir investir là
dedans
au québec seulement 25% du plastique et
recyclés presque tout le reste est
envoyé à l'enfouissement
le gouvernement du québec devrait nous
écouter premièrement devrait avoir une
volonté probante de faire bouger les
choses dans l'industrie on croit que le
gouvernement du québec devrait forcer
les entreprises à avoir un contenu de
matières recyclées faudrait obliger les
gens au québec
sweex prennent la matière première qui
prennent aussi leur cité oui le
gouvernement du québec devrait obliger
de le faire mais le gouvernement du
québec devrait aussi obliger le
consommateur à acheter des produits qui
sont faites de respect deux ans après la
crise qui a frappé le secteur du
recyclage les défis demeurent
considérables tant pour l'industrie que
pour le gouvernement du québec alors
qu'on parle de plus en plus d'économie
circulaire et si jean-philippe robien
radio canada montréal